tan breve como contundente esta
declaración firmada por más de 350
expertos en tecnología hace un llamado a
los responsables políticos mitigar el
riesgo de extinción por la Inteligencia
artificial Debería ser una prioridad
global junto a otros riesgos a escala
social como las pandemias y la guerra
nuclear el centro para la seguridad de
la Inteligencia artificial señala varios
escenarios catastróficos como que las
herramientas de descubrimiento de
fármacos se utilizan para crear armas
químicas o el debilitamiento en el que
la humanidad pierde la capacidad de
autogobernarse y pasa a depender
completamente de las máquinas entre Los
partidarios de la declaración se
encuentran ejecutivos de Google y
Microsoft y Goofy Hilton considerado uno
de los padrinos de la Inteligencia
artificial
en cuanto a la amenaza existencial creo
que quizá Estados Unidos china Europa y
Japón puedan cooperar para intentar
evitar esa amenaza existencial pero la
cuestión es como hacerlo creo que
detener el desarrollo no es factible
otras figuras de la industria sin
embargo dicen que los temores en torno a
la extinción humana son exagerados y
muchos creen que el verdadero problema
de la ia es la reproducción de
prejuicios aprendidos en sistemas
racistas O excluyentes
creo que estos son algunos de los
ámbitos la contratación y el empleo es
uno los préstamos abusivos son otro el
acceso a la vivienda el acceso a
oportunidades de desarrollo como la
admisión en la universidad y en la
escuela
la declaración sigue a una carta mucho
más larga firmada por más de mil
expertos incluido y los musk consejero
delegado de tesla en ella se pedía Una
pausa en el desarrollo de la
Inteligencia artificial de Nueva
Generación
advirtiendo que las Mentes no humanas
podrían llegar a ser más inteligentes y
sustituirlos